[Musique]
merci pour frankenstein mais constant
qui s'est adapté à 2015
mesdames et messieurs la médecine du
futur immédiat c'est à dire de demain
depuis du futur n'est pas et ne sera pas
celle d'hier ni encore moins du passé
parce que la médecine du passé se basait
sur se base jusqu'à aujourd'hui sur
l'utilisation de médicaments
les médicaments fait ne sont là que pour
corriger guillemets je parle de maladie
grave hein ce qu'on appelle les
traitements mais ya pas de guérison
totale dans beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de malades et donc la médecine
on est à cheval là aujourd'hui entre les
deux en médecine du futur la médecine de
demain tu médecine régénératrice
réparatrice génératif je veux dire par
là une médecine de remplacement on
remplace des pièces ces deux mécaniciens
qui voulait un raccourci qui défaillance
de dynamos j'ai pas d'âme alternateur
d'un démarreur on enlève et en place sa
médecine actuelle qui est en train de se
développer et la médecine régénérative
régénératrice on peut même aller plus
loin régénérer des organes fabriquer des
à partir de cellules ce qu'on appelle
cellules souches
elles sont à l'origine de tout de toutes
les cellules de l'organisme
c'est le souches sont d'actualité
le pardon dans cette diapositive n'a pas
été agrandi mais c'est pas grave tout
récents elle représente c'est une
diapositive qui a nourri qui est d'être
de l'antiquité qui a nourri l'imaginaire
de générations en générations
puisqu'il s'agit d'une greffe d'une
jambe une jambe noir prélevés sur un
individu de couleur noire réfléchi un
patient blanc c'est juste pour montrer
l'écart génétique la différence
génétique
c'est comme dans les souris de
laboratoire sur ebook sur une war etc
ce sont deux frères médecin saint côme
et saint damien
ce sont des médecins arabes chrétiens
qui opérait au niveau en gros au niveau
de la cité actuelle act actuelle donc
cette jambe
vous imaginez jusqu'aujourd'hui
c'est difficile parce que le problème de
roger s'est pas seulement noir et blanc
même entre nous entre noirs entre blonde
chinois tout ce que vous voulez vous
greffé il faut que ça soit compatible ce
qu'on appelle listo compatibilité c'est
à dire les tissus pour qu'ils soient
compatibles qui pas de roger ça a valu
un prix nobel
j'endosse et à paris en 1958 à
déterminer c'est groupes tissulaires qui
permettent de déterminer si quelqu'un
peut être greffés ou pas surtout un
donneur d'organes on a un receveur qui
attendent un rein un coeur un poumon
un fois tout ce que vous voulez il
faudrait chercher en donnant pour qu'ils
puissent incompatibles on a beau vous
donnez le comme cadeau un organe n'est
pas compatible rejetée ça c'est la loi
de l'immunologie
il ya que des situations de fer jumeaux
personne n'at on n'a pas tous ses
jumeaux ou bien trouvés dans la nature
quelqu'un qui vous soit compatible et
qui a le même adn que vous ce moment là
vous avez la chance de le regretter
sans qu'il y ait de roger
cette diapositive ce tableau il a nourri
l'imaginaire dès jeudi des chercheurs et
des médecins
c'est un parcours intéressant
un parcours l'an semé d'embûches mais
passionnant parce que ce qui nous dit
pas ce tableau donc c'est très beau ce
qu'on voit que quand même sa date et on
voit des personnes qui s'intéressent à
essayer de greffe et de soigner et
prendre donc des organes c'est le défi
d'aujourd'hui de pouvoir greffer tout le
monde qui ait pas de pénurie d'organes
c'est ça le drame on ne peut pas parce
que même si on trouve des donneurs ce
n'est pas possible à cause de cette
fameuse loi biologique de queue qui est
la génétique du de la reconnaissance du
choix du nom soit parce que votre
système qui acceptent ou qui rejette
dans la plupart des cas c'est le système
immunitaire le système immunitaire
fonctionne selon un concept qui est là
la différence la reconnaissance du soi
et du nom soit il fait la différence à
vodafone organe s'est pas à vous ils
attaquent donc le reconnaît il arrive à
faire dans dix autres le soin et des
anglo saxons le self or not safe
je reviens ce tableau j'ai placé un peu
j'ai planté le décor immunologique pour
vous soyez imprégnés de cette culture
c'est un peu complexe mais ce sera plus
facile pour pour la suite
cette diapos ne nous dit pas si sa jambe
a été acceptée ou rejetée mais entre
nous
doucement dû être rejetées ce que le
défi actuellement c'est ça
c'est une image qui peut peut-être
choquer les âmes sensibles cette greffe
de visage
il s'agit du gard de visage
ce monsieur se porte très bien vous
savez des grandes maladies des cancers
de la face des déformations des maladies
génétiques vous avez des gens que vous
pouvez même pas regarder cela a été
possible
on aurait on l'aurait pas fait si on
sait baasiste convient de voir pas par
la jante
ça aurait été rejetée on peut vous
pouvez greffer un coeur un rendement
tout ce que vous voulez il sera rejeté
on va pas aller que se compliquer les
choses
avec la grâce d'un visage si c'est
rejeter mais c'est ce n'est plus
possible
c'est à dire là je peux dire la bourse
la grève est possible sans qu'ils aient
de roger ce qu'on appelle actuellement
qui fait l'objet encore de sujets de
recherche l'écu commence à être
appliquée dans les premières greffes du
visage c'est l'induction de la tolérance
c'est possible donc si on avait greffé
classiquement comme la jambe de tout à
l'heure dans trois mois et ce sera aux
jetons mais là l'astuce le secret ya pas
de sucre et en sciences une façon de
parler
c'est au préalable avant de greffe et ce
visage ça aurait pu être un coeur des
bras être autre chose c'est d'avoir
préparé le recevoir chez eux ce monsieur
là qui est allongé avant du greffe de
visage
nous avons prélevé sur le patient qui a
donné ce visage des cellules souches
c'est les cellules souches sont des
cellules qui
je trouve au niveau de la moelle osseuse
au niveau des eaux et qui permettent de
fabriquer toutes les cellules de
l'organisme et en particulier celle qui
circule dans le sens des globules blancs
les globules rouges
le foie le coeur les poumons et c'est
tout ce que vous voulez démarrent à
partir des cellules souches
donc si on avait greffé le visage du
faso classiques comme la jambe de tout à
l'heure ça a été rejetée mais là nous
avons préparé leur saveur en lui
injectant préalable les cellules souches
prélevées chez celui qui a donné le
visage est ensuite entré dans le visage
en le greffe sur le fasse sur le
receveur à ce moment là c'est tout à
fait différent
ce visage cet organe greffé va se
trouver dans un contexte non agressif
c'est à dire les cellules souches
prélevées chez le donneur d'organes ont
permis de protéger ce visage donc sur
parrot jetez donc c'est ça qui va le
défendre
le visage le greffon va se retrouver en
face d'un système qu'il connaît s'il a
été greffée d'emblée sans qu' une
solution derrière ils se retrouvaient
dans un milieu hostile
chez un receveur qu'il ne connaît pas le
receveur va réagir duval rejetée donc il
faut au préalable à porter les cellules
souches
je répète et ensuite greffé le visage
ainsi ce visage intégré vu par la suite
mais il ya eu le visage les bras et tout
dernièrement un utérus
j'ai une femme des suites cet utérus à
fonctionner
cette somme a mis en route une grossesse
et elle accouché d'un enfant c'est
pareil donc les bras ce n'est pas rien a
prélevé des bras chez quelqu'un pour
prélever la moelle osseuse auparavant
c'est-à-dire les cellules souches et
c'est pour camper le visage pour
l'utérus est pareil avant de prélever
les terrains sont à prélever la moelle
des cellules souches
après préparons le receveur ensuite on
met l'utérus
et puis et puis ça fonctionne
tout à fait parfaitement donc la
première greffe avant de ce visage un
peu impressionnant que je vous ai montré
la première greffe
juste avant le visage complet c'était à
peu près les trois les trois cas d'un
visage
c'est cette dame sa première que nous
avons greffé à lyon donc elle a été donc
voyez un peu le schéma l1 peut donner
une correction à son chien n'avait un
retrait l'air qui l'a agressé qui lui a
arraché par sa beauté du visage dans
tout ça a été un petit peu la situation
et il la voilà aujourd'hui
cette dame avait un visage au début qui
est m
a maastricht puisque greffer un visage
visage soit expressif qui monte des
émotions autour donc et cela était
possible sinon si ça reste un masque
c'est rejeter c'est que bien sûr
techniquement il ya les connexions qui
ont été faites derrière des nerfs et des
vaisseaux essentiel ensuite le reste
fait fait la suite
donc on on a vu évoluer cette dame
voyez aujourd'hui
et voilà juste quelques joueurs avaient
sonné avait juste après son opération
son visage était figé cette dame je
connais personnellement puisque nous la
suivant dans le service et regarde donc
voilà ce qui a été refait il tu as tout
ça ne bougeait pas elle passait toujours
avec une écharpe elle cacher son visage
est aujourd'hui regardez elle sourit et
c'est un visage qui fonctionne et tout
est en place
donc je reviens pour vous dire que
l'essentiel est dans les cellules
souches et c'est monsieur qui sont dans
les eaux et qui permettent de fabriquer
du foie du muscle de la peau tout ce que
vous voulez peut être fabriqué par les
cellules souches ce sont celles en fait
qui constitue le secret de de l'histoire
ces cellules souches nous pouvons les
prendre dans le laboratoire au niveau de
certains endroits chez le foetus au
niveau de la classe normale vont les
isoler le met les mettre en culture
ensuite mettre des ingrédients dessus
des facteurs de croissance
ensuite ça dépend du facteur de
croissance nous les connaissons pas tous
mais certains facteurs croissance
quand nous lui rajoutant nous drivant
nous nous aidons les cellules a évolué
vers si on veut faire du coeur ont
rajouté et gardians et ça va vous donner
des cellules quand vous les regardez
microscope ici dans cette boîte de pétri
des cellules qu'ils vont battre comme un
coeur pour m si on met les ingrédients
qui permettait à fabriquer du foie vous
aurez un tissu hépatique 6 2 pour le
poumon pour tout ce que vous voulez vous
pouvez le généré mais il faut identifier
tous les facteurs et ces facteurs ne
sont pas tous connus
nous pouvons faire de la peau ne pouvant
faire de coeur ne pouvant faire du
poumon un petit peu de fois mais pas
mais pas tous mais pas tous les organes
donc et il a été possible donc ainsi de
prendre des cellules
souches chez un patient qui avait une
défaillance cardiaque grave ça a été mis
en culture en attendant de lui trouver
un coeur bien sûr ça a été mis en
culture propre avec les facteurs de
croissance qui permet de générer du
tissu cardiaque du myocarde
ensuite ça a été injectée au niveau du
coeur et ça a construit le coeur qui
était défaillant et qui dans lequel il
allait y avoir un trou donc nous pouvons
même greffer des cellules humaines de
foetus humain chez la souris
ça c'est pour faire des modèles
deux laboratoires qui permettent de
traiter des maladies rares comme par
exemple lorsque nous avons mis au point
le système pour piéger le virus du sida
puisque le virus du sida n'a fait que
les cellules humaines et vous ne pouvez
pas travailler face d'espérance infecté
un homme avec le vih sida
donc vous vous devez construire un
modèle qui fabrique de un système
immunitaire fonctionnel chez la souris
ensuite vous pouvez travailler chez les
souris aisément cette diapositive qui va
peut être vous choquer mais elle est
très belle
je vais vous dire pourquoi nous avons
greffé ce qu'on appelle mains pieds et
un une main intégré sur un pied chez
quelqu'un qui n'a pas dû il est né sans
bras
il n'y a pas de bras au niveau même au
niveau des articulations des épaules il
va devoir donc un donneur demain il va a
été prélevée la moelle osseuse c'est le
chouchou bien sûr avec pour que ce soit
pas rejetée parce que sinon ça sert à
rien ensuite ça permet quelqu'un qui n'a
pas de bras haut niveau donc au niveau
supérieur
ça va lui permettre de prendre les
objets dont elle est coincée entre le
creux de 2 donc de la cheville et le
bras donc donc sans bras sa main va
pouvoir prendre et manipulé tout ce
qu'il veut donc voila un petit peu j'ai
dépassé mon temps je tiens à vous
remercier pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]